pues esa es la pregunta clave yo creo
que tan posible es poder realmente
llevar a cabo lo que están prometiendo
que al final no olvidemos que estamos en
medio de una pandemia se está quitando a
sesták y está aprovechando de esa parte
en la que miles de estadounidenses han
perdido a algún familiar o han sufrido
el coronavirus y se han dado cuenta del
sistema sanitario que atraque tiene el
país y cuáles son las digamos las
carencias que tiene entonces es una es
una muy buena línea de pues de utilizar
para conseguir votantes en esta en esta
campaña pero ojo porque no es tan real a
la hora de aplicarla y luego también
dentro del mismo partido demócrata no se
acaban de poner de acuerdo entre lo que
quiere el ala más izquierdista y la que
no no debemos olvidar que como decía
nuestra compañía diana bernís antes
llega a estas convenciones con bastante
poder con unos con un gran número de
delegados y al final dentro del mismo
partido vemos esa unidad que se está
intentando transmitir en todo momento
pero hasta qué punto es real
entonces pues bueno en la cuestión del
coronavirus también tenemos que tener en
cuenta que vaivén se ha dado cuenta de
que le ha funcionado es decir el
candidato demócrata ha estado durante
casi cinco meses encerrado en su casa
haciendo una campaña virtual que le ha
funcionado hasta qué punto no le ha
funcionado la campaña virtual o le ha
funcionado el colocarse al lado de los
estadounidenses y estar con ellos en esa
lucha contra el coronavirus apoyarle
abrazarles no cosa que no hemos visto
por parte igual del presidente don al
tram y entonces ha sabido utilizar
perfectamente como como bueno pues como
herramienta para esta lucha en la
cuestión del coronavirus y sobre todo la
cuestión de la cobertura médica con
todos los problemas que estamos viendo
ahora que están aflorando